foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
quisite to be on this show you have to
scream at the beginning this is our
daily news show that keeps you updated
on all the nerdy news that you need to
know coming up on the episode of course
we're talking about the stranger things
chapter 4 Volume 2 finale we've got a
sneak peek at Loki season two
um and some Wolverine
potential recasting news that I want to
get everyone's opinion on but before we
begin
um I am joined today by Tick Tock famous
no Angelica dress yeah congratulations
um no but if you watch any rockstars you
know Angelica well
um also if you watched new rockstars you
know Erica wusu hey hey hey hey hey hey
Tick Tock famous adjacent uh Jason
The Tick Tock Fame is rubbing awful yeah
all of our follower numbers are going up
after this episode especially koi jandro
yeah he's back so excited to be here and
I can officially say something I was
going to announce last week but I
couldn't oh you're in the Greater Los
Angeles area I'm hosting the Thor
Marathon for Marvel so if you guys are
here you want to come I couldn't be in
Austin but that's going to be rad I'm so
excited and Thunder and the Ragnarok and
the Dark World and Thor starting at 6
a.m are you going in reverse order
apparently I am let's see how that works
out for me okay great
um if you are new joining us today we
have our favorite Redemption which is
the reverse Square jar basically what
happens is we're going to be asking you
later on in the show for your stranger
things season five theories your
predictions even some comments that you
had on this this latest season and if
you do that in the form of a super chat
um it adds a little bit of money at the
bottom of the screen toward our hey
Joshua can we take on that uh that
overlay there
um that's the wrong one there it is
um you can see at the bottom that that
adds to our swear jar basically if we
collect enough money the FCC has said it
will pay for the fine of swearing on the
show we're not allowed to swear
otherwise I know this is news2 Angelica
um so we will unleash a bevy of swears
um and and we thank you very much for
allowing us to do that but first we have
to get into the headlines
crap oh yeah I always feel like I have
to talk over that graphic it makes me
uncomfortable when they're silent
stranger things chapter 4 Volume 2 came
out over the weekend like I said please
please we say this we mean it put your
questions your thoughts your theories
into the comments off screen producer
Dodson is going to collect all of those
over to the side we're going to talk
about them in a bit but before we do
that I want to get your guys's sort of
one sentence spoiler free we're not
quite into spoiler territory yet sort of
review thoughts on chapter four as a
whole koi
a beautiful way to evolve the mythology
season to season while escalating the
stakes in a way that feels both
rewarding and enticing for season five
okay great that was you I really want a
game
good Eric
see what koi said yeah yeah
a lore-filled uh an entertaining bloody
tear-jerker messy event okay yeah Eric
did text this morning he was he said yes
I'm caught up on Stranger Things I was
crying all week yeah
let them know we'll be talking about it
I might cry again
how much crying did you do I I did all I
did crying here and there and then I was
just mostly enthralled by like what was
going on the entire time just trying to
figure out like oh can can you know if
this person's not looking too hot right
now can they can things turn around can
we 180 here I would definitely say that
season four is piecing everything
together it's making all of the seasons
start to fall into place and make a lot
of sense and I I definitely sense that
we're moving towards this grand season I
am so excited for the next one I have so
many theories I definitely have my
notepad out being like okay yes that
person could still die that person feels
like maybe not
um we're going to come back to stranger
things here in a minute if you're just
joining us but first uh there's some
other cool headlines that we want to
talk about uh this weekend Loki started
shooting in London they were doing some
exteriors and we love it when projects
shoot exteriors because we got a little
bit of a glimpse at what they might be
cooking up um I think we have some
photos that that surfaced online from
Loki season two here they are a couple
of interesting things to note obviously
first thing that stands out is Kingo
there in the middle
um
but it seems like they're going to be at
some sort of like past event in some
some sort of movie theater situation but
there are also these two Side characters
that I think are really weird
um first is zaniac who I think has four
appearances in Marvel Comics I could be
wrong and I was doing my research the
super obscure Thor villain from the
1980s but I love it he is like
um he's sort of like the it follows
creature where if you kill zaniac he
just like comes back in in like
repossesses someone so this is like
Marvel Run where it was like oh he was
possessing Jack the Ripper he was
possessing all these like famous serial
killers so
um in the Marvel Comics there was an
actor named uh Brad wolf who was doing a
move this is all in in the comics
there's an actor named Brad wolf doing a
movie playing this fictional character
zaniac and then gets possessed by zaniac
um which I think it would be a very fun
storyline I don't know if we'll go there
but it might just be a wink and a nod um
and then it's also this poster for phone
Ranger who was another sort of obscure
Marvel character though I could be I
could be mistaken there who would
protect people's phone
not a joke
I had to do the research uh people in
the comments could correct me if my
research wasn't in-depth enough but uh I
love it
they're weekly yeah sometimes you need
to put those characters in to move the
plot along and phone Rangers happen
there's been a lot of times where I've
we have some great researchers here at
new rock stars and I've like popped a
question into our new Rockstar slack and
I've been like is there a legitimate
explanation for why this happens or is
it because Comics
sometimes it's because comics and
sometimes there's a legitimate
explanation
um I also want to bring up dashlaw if
you could pull up that other image this
was on stage Kevin feige announcing Loki
we have like this blurred out photo of
who I think is Tom Hiddleston as Loki
standing in front of a Jaws Marquee that
was supposed to be for season one we
never got that scene I don't think
um so I'll be curious to know that maybe
they're bringing some things from season
one into season two or something like
that yeah maybe with the TVA and time
travel like you you there is no wasted
footage like as long as this works for
the story you can do so much with that's
a good point yeah anything's possible to
like actually anything is possible and
the Mischief is just like playful you
can really like we wouldn't even mind
continuity issues and like I'm really
curious what this season's going to be
because it's got a new Duo running it uh
Justin and Aaron are taking over and so
that's gonna be a different flavor and
it's also going to be a different uh
it's the first sequel show so like it's
gonna be a different expectations season
too yeah yeah so I'm really curious if
that's going to be will we still have
the six episode thing will that change
as we get into phase two of the episode
like you know what I mean like will that
evolve as the movies have like I'm
really curious about this right yeah
very interesting also in other Marvel
news ilm visual effects supervisor
Julian fatty uh gave an interview over
the weekend that uh he sort of said oh
yeah the the note for turning
um Reed Richards into spaghetti was a
was a Kevin feige original I just love
that we get these like little tidbits of
like oh yeah that was feige's idea or
whatever
um just because you know I wouldn't have
expected him to be really involved in
the day to day of of sort of those small
decisions but I would just I love it
like feige's getting out of bed and he's
like it'd be funny if if he turned it
exactly what it was
um it was supposed to be like someone
passing a lump of Plato through a garlic
press which I think is like a really
funny visual to begin with
um but yeah it's an interesting little
detail I also love the idea of like
Kevin foggy being like all right what's
it gonna look like it's like the idea of
like that being his mind's eye or like
okay we gotta work this out let's work
shopping Mr Fantastic I would love to
know I'm sure there's a document
somewhere of all of the presumable you
know Illuminati characters that they
could have pulled from and then a little
Dash and how Wanda kills them I want
that I know it somewhere yeah I want
that document so badly yeah I wonder if
you would lead with that too like if he
came in when I want this to happen this
to happen or if it all happened you know
in post or anything I don't know that's
a great question I also want to see the
all like scenes from that movie because
like we've heard there's so many
ultimate options like I don't know if
they've been feeling I don't know if
there's previous but even other
characters we almost got like there's
there's phase four love it or hate it is
the most what-ifs for lack of better
term there's so much that we don't know
that could have been a different
narrative and I do think we're about a
month out
from finding out what all of this
cohesion is look at that I'm just saying
I think it's coming I think it may be
two weeks maybe uh ten weeks but I think
I'm one of those two days I'm leaving 10
weeks but uh I hope it's two weeks I'd
like two weeks I think I think two weeks
we get the Infinity War to the 10 weeks
is end game okay okay the Cliffhanger I
don't hear that I think I think once
it's coming I think there's me like
here's enough information to make you
want to come in 10 weeks like I think
we'll see I do I do want to be there in
10 weeks if you don't know what we're
talking about we're talking about but
we've talked about it isn't good enough
San Diego Comic-Con is coming up in a
couple of weeks Marvel is doing a panel
there we have no idea what to expect and
then following that in September like
the 7th through the 11th or something
like that is Disney's d23 where we're
expecting a lot of other Marvel
announcements and Disney plus day is in
there were you surprised by the
announcement that Saturday Hall age was
like that kind of I didn't expect it
because of how big d23 has been
historically for Marvel I thought there
was no chance yeah yeah I was like well
we have we have San Diego Comic-Con off
because DC is doing fandom although I
think there's still going to be a
Comic-Con and it felt like it was going
to be a relatively uneventful weekend
yeah I'm excited but we're gonna have
some cool stuff to talk about in a
couple weeks I feel like we have two
Adventure cons that's right yeah that's
right
um speaking of Avenger con nope bad
transition
volume three James gone can't stay off
Twitter this man can't have Twitter he
said it's going to be probably drax's
last movie but more interestingly he's
so he also says it's the end of the
story for this group of Guardians
do we think it's the end for all of them
uh do you think James Gunn doesn't
really have a a
a say in the future
they really are his characters at the
end of the day since they're pretty
different from where they started in the
comics and
um since he really popularized them uh I
don't know do you think that this is
really the last outing for these guys I
mean I hope not I mean we have volume
three coming next year something like
that we've got we've got uh the
Christmas special happening this year
and then yeah volume three coming up and
then there's a group thing coming
because coming in November or something
like that something like that yeah so I
mean we'll we'll see I mean
Gamora is not in it as far as Thor 11
Thunder as far as we've seen so they
could do some you know reshuffling of
characters bring some people in take
some people out have group be on
whatever path yeah yeah he's like a
young adult by this point I imagine
paying rent I'm wondering if we're gonna
get the fully formed Groot again as a
swan song like if if Guardian history is
the end do we finish it like we began
like is it Vin Diesel doing adult group
that we met in Guardians one as like an
oroborus like a symmetry because I do
feel like this could be the end of the
Guardians like James Gunn likes to kill
people
I don't think
I don't know who would want to touch
those characters right and they've had
what you just described uh three to come
and they've had to and they've appeared
in three others that's eight appearances
I could be forgetting one or two that so
that's kind of the Run we've had with
these characters if you look at what
we've got with short of cameos that's
kind of the general Arc amount we get
yeah so that could be the end you bring
up a good point you know we talked about
how quickly they made a whole trilogy of
Spider-Man films in between doctor
strange and Doctor Strange and the
Multiverse of Madness but uh I mean
Guardians the Galaxy came out before
Doctor Strange if I've got my timeline
correct but that is a ton of appearances
of those characters even with Guardians
of the Galaxy vol 3 getting sort of
delayed and we're getting a lot at once
we're getting a holiday special and
Guardians 3 back to back year to year
and Groot in the middle yeah plus Thor
their their involvement in thorough and
thunder it's a lot of Guardians it's a
good way to send them off yeah
but we are getting new characters right
and newest of them all is she Hulk
Tatiana maslani who's playing She-Hulk
and Jennifer Walters said in an
interview
that this is sort of the the She-Hulk
project is the antithesis of most
superhero narratives and what she meant
by that as she she went on to clarify
um she said for me it was about
rejecting what had happened for as long
as I could talking about the character
and that is what causes the fun tension
between Jennifer and She-Hulk I guess
Jennifer is like yeah I don't I don't
want this
and I'm sure Bruce is like I don't know
put the brains in the brawn together and
I'm having a great time and she's like I
am green a giant
how I feel about that that'll be a
really interesting way to sort of you
know who Among Us would not be thrilled
to have superpowers it'll be an
interesting story to have the opposite
of that take place right yeah I feel
like with Miss Marvel in the comic books
we had that great like puberty
commentary of like feeling alien weird
by her body dysmorphia and stuff but
I've always felt like She-Hulk has a
similar thing with like being almost a
self-awareness she breaks the fourth
wall before Deadpool does so her
self-awareness gives us an eye line into
what it might be like for one of us to
have powers so I think using the medium
of film and especially using dating
which we see what it's like to feel
exposed and feel alien and to feel like
you know an other we get to see that
like maybe on dates because that's
always heightened so maybe the dating is
how she's like coping with this new
thing and then breaking the fourth wall
so we feel it which is interesting she
did kind of on the other side of the
show she did kind of talk about how what
you're sort of alluding to with this
fourth wall stuff is like there's gonna
be some wacky superheroes that she is
defending right she's like I mean frog
man's in the tree yeah right super super
goofy I'm excited to see sort of like
the camp dial sort of ratcheted up for
that show and see what weird obscure
freaking Telephone Man characters that
we get in that show that'll be a lot of
fun okay we've got uh a couple more
things we want to get to before we I've
been talking way too much uh before we
get to stranger things
um Rocket Man Star I don't know why
we're proceeding with that
Taryn Edgerton I'm sure everyone saw
this online this weekend we've been off
for four days we have old news to talk
about because we want to talk about it
um he said that he was talking to Kevin
feige himself
um and about maybe a possible Wolverine
role here's what he said he said I don't
think it would be wrong to say that I
don't know what the question was that
proceeded at the article did not say
um he said I'd be excited but
apprehensive as well because Hugh is so
associated with the role and I'd wonder
if it would be very difficult for
someone else to do it but then he paused
and flashed a grin and said but
hopefully if it does come around they'll
give me a shot I think this is great
casting right I I maybe you guys
disagree with me uh I think you would be
super fun I could see it I mean you know
Wolverine is a little short and stocky
in the comic sure Taryn is definitely
not the six one six two Hugh Jackman so
I think that would help and that'd be a
different feel and look to Wolverine so
he could like place his own path with
that and I need to have to put on I was
40 pounds of muscle you would have to
put on a little bit of muscle I would
also love to see like I feel like Taryn
has done more like clean like Kingsman
he's very like proper right it'll be
really fun if if he does end up being
cast to see like another side of him
where he's got like a cigar in his mouth
and he's like grizzled and got the
facial hair and all that and more bub I
feel like Hugh Jackman didn't say but
yeah
it's all for Bob I guess this guy could
look like the the burn like the John
burn Arrow which is how I picture your
Wolverine like he is very small and very
round and that you earned that Bub and I
like he's been one of my three from the
beginning I've always wanted Tom Hardy's
now Venom but still would be great do
you just have like a hole Yeah
with that but it's Tom Hardy Edgar
Ramirez and Taryn Edgerton those have
always been my three so to hear this and
then you know the Eagles Taryn Edgerton
uh I also you know the two of them but
he's got Hugh Jackman's blessing they
did press for the eagle and Hugh Jackman
said he'd want him to take on the claws
he said in interviews that if anyone's
gonna take on the mantle clearly it's
stuck and if you're gonna listen to
someone about who should be Wolverine
you listen to your dragon so I will say
books there has been like a weird phase
four thing where our actors are just
like asking for roles
I'm sure there's a couple of other
people have been like hey cast me in a
thing maybe we'll have to it's a it's a
running joke at this point when I see
another headline with that it's like an
active everybody saying I would like to
play this role like is this an
application yeah everybody we should all
get on our phones right now and just
tweet Marvel Studios Marvel I would like
to host for you please and thank you
this is the Tweet we're doing we're
doing the floor you're you're close
I also think there's a specific name
Taryn a lot of people aren't talking
about is that if you look at the
progression of phase four they've
systematically added in comic accurate
costumes and if you look at the trailers
for Thor love and thunder the that's
been pushed to an 11. like what the new
Thor costume is the new yeah new Thor
costume is has a full cowl if anyone can
rock the jawline required for the actual
Wolverine hair Taryn Edgerton I think
we're gonna go comic accurate with the
costumes I think the X-Men are gonna
look like their 90s Jim Lee run and I
think you need to make sure your people
cast can pull off the visor without not
being able to emote James Marsden did
what he could but a lot of the times
they didn't give them dialogue that
compensated for the mask that
compensated for his lack of eye
connectivity so you didn't get to feel
for him I think we've learned that
lesson we're gonna have comic accurate
costumes you need to cast appropriately
for those looks separate of the singer
look that's what I I hope interesting I
like that I think it's where we're going
I think we're going full kind of gecko
by the interface I think you're right
right like the the I don't know why I
remember this conversation but when the
trailer for civil war came out and we
saw Spider-Man land on top of the bus
with the Captain America shield and he's
like I he's moved we were like oh they
figured something out that's going to be
really crucial and yeah you're right the
costuming department at Marvel Studios
has been Second To None all of these
stupid Goofy looks from the comics that
we know and love are like so good well I
think it's a societal thing right like
and I'm sorry because I have this my
obsession we get stranger things I
promise but if you look at societally
we've now gone from blade which was like
setting up beautifully Matrix in those
costumes but then X-Men followed that up
because that was the standard that's
what accepted then the comics had to
replicate that with the Graham Morrison
new X-Men run but over time with Society
accepting comic books look at the
bullets the boys costumes look like they
could walk out and there's a valkyrie ad
that's actually Valkyrie advertising
something that looks like a boys ad and
you'll also see boys ads on the side of
Amazon trucks that are actually
delivering stuff that they train on it
yeah so our line between reality and
fiction is blurred and I think that's
why we can accept these costumes because
we're seeing things like it in real life
and we're accepting costumes and
characters that wear them in our life so
you can do the extreme because we are
there but I think we had to get there
yeah I think and I think that they've
slowly sort of laid the groundwork for
us getting there yeah right well I think
it's also a reflection of how the MCO
has changed too because it you know
maybe like a decade ago it used to be so
serious and now we're starting to see
things lighten up a bit and we're
bringing in these quote unquote maybe
goofier 90s costumes and so I definitely
think it's a reflection of that it's
like oh we can make things light but
also keep in that sentimentality keeping
those really special moments that make
everyone cry because I cry and pretty
much to every MCU movie ever now they do
it so well I know I've also heard a lot
and I don't know what you guys think
about this but I've heard a lot of folks
wanting uh fan casting for Daniel
Radcliffe for Wolverine as well oh you
haven't heard that one no really yeah oh
my God that'd be interesting I feel like
every time the conversation comes up
because I'm a Hugh Jackman fan like I
grew up with Hugh Jackman as my my Logan
but uh I someone always mentions Daniel
Radcliffe I mean it makes sense he's
very short
he's very short he's pretty hairy yeah
the maybe the jawline and stuff to the
dark hair yeah yeah I just hear that one
all the time I think he's a very
talented actor but I would like to see
some rage from him before I like I'm not
saying he's not it I just haven't seen
the thing that would make me go I
wouldn't Fan cast him myself because I
haven't seen that one element but I'm
not saying he's not capable of it I just
would like to see it before I put that
in the okay the Arsenal so I'm picking
up a lot of skepticism here he's just
precious
he is I mean but after
um uh Heath Ledger did so well with the
joker yeah you can't you can't prejudge
an actor based on their resume anyone
can surprise you yeah so I'd love to see
Harry Potter be Logan did you just have
one of those where we were like I mean
people were like Colin Farrell should be
the penguin rabbit patterns and Jimmy
Batman like the entire cast of Batman oh
yeah that was what it was it was Robert
and also everybody's saying Carl Urban
who would be great like Carl Urban is
Wolverine as butcher but unfortunately
if you're gonna want this guy to play
him for 15 20 years like I love Carl
Urban but he's a human being yeah so age
will occur and while speaking of which
though right we just saw some like weird
de-aging stuff happening on stranger
things with uh oh let's put this spoiler
thing up let's put the Damn Sport there
we go we just saw some like de-aging
stuff happening in stranger things with
eleven being in the whatever you want to
call that rainbow room yeah sure I don't
know yeah the scary torture replacement
Nina
um well I'm I'm sort of talking about
the whole facility we saw we see her
flashing back too right and you have a
lot of shots of present day 11 in memory
mode but then we also get you know past
11 in that
um scene too so I could see a way where
they just like fully lean into de-aging
people digitally and they're like yeah
we could play you know these characters
play these characters for forever it
doesn't matter
no but I think
it might not feel so limited I would
love that I think it's time to move on
speaking of time to move on I am done
talking uh koi let's talk about stranger
things all right so stranger things if
you're not caught up this is your
spoiler this is your last warning this
is all we can do for you stranger things
chapter 4 Volume 2 dropped over the
weekend and I have a ton of questions as
I'm sure you all do as well and we've
got a whole bunch of questions we're
going to queue up but I want to know
final predictions who is in charge this
final season do we think it's the Mind
flayer do we think it's vekna do we
think it's someone new
um there was that line in the first
batch of episodes where Dustin says like
you know if a demogorgon is the mind
flayers soldier then vectus is five star
general that threw me so hard because I
was like oh no vechna is like the guy
right yeah
um so that's really what's bumping me
because I am sort of like we've got this
great origin story for vecna
um really fun acting super interesting I
mean they you know an interesting place
to go has relation to the characters
that we love has a brain too right right
and I would have expected vacana to be
sort of the big bad for the season or
the series but we have also like the
Mind flayer yeah doing two seasons of
stuff and they're working to get I don't
know so we got one got one for veto your
vote I think it should be back okay I
want to keep tally okay all right so um
we'll check the tapes
I know so uh from the vecina backstory
uh I got the impression that the Mind
flare was puppeteered by vecna this
whole time right so from season two so I
think that vecna is going to be the big
bad right because that is just such a
formidable opponent anyone that can
stand up against 11 but also he is
puppeteering right Master of Puppets you
know we're bringing a full circle here
the Mind Flame here and so
he's creating this hive mind and he's
going to take over so okay my vote's
Rebecca as well we got two solid Vector
that one feels very concrete yeah yeah I
feel like it's going to be the Mind
flare because because in that backstory
uh vecma got into the upside down and
the mind flare was already there being
all partically so like that is the OG
evil demon villain so and and like kind
of fused with vechna to make Beck know
what he is so I think what's gonna
happen in season five is the Mind flayer
is gonna
continue to work with vecna to try to do
some stuff I think 11 and the Gang are
gonna finish him but I think the Mind
flare is going to fuse with Will
and and puppet will and it's gonna be a
big Showdown with like will mind flayer
versus 11 in the gang I will say to your
point about the Mind flare sort of
having been there we do not to always
bring things back to Marvel but like an
Elias he who remains situation where
you're like cool you're here and you're
mine now and we're gonna go have some
fun I think so so my take is similar in
that Henry said he created the Mind
player right didn't he mention in the in
the upside down that he sorry no he
didn't create manipulated the mind
because he was shaping it sorry not
created but like was shaping it so I'm
wondering if we've got a situation where
the Mind flayer might join with him
physically because like the demogorgon
so maybe it goes from him manipulating
him to the the Mind flare and then we've
got one Mega boss but I do think on the
journey will does get possessed I think
I think it might go like they gotta
fight will as the mini boss and then it
infects and then they become one unit
and we get like a body transformation we
did all that so I think the answer is
yes we have I love that we haven't
really had any like Cronenberg horses
yet and we've talked about each season
s broke the kids I don't know the
Billy's
season three oh that's right
with the rats and everything you're
right you're right you're right you're
right the flash monster is very
incredible I take it all back oh that's
right that's right oh George Romero and
all zombie stuff and then you know
everything I do think it was a zombie
season you're right that is like that is
wraps like exploding and forming a
creature so they definitely touch on the
Cronenberg you're right but
transformation wise we haven't seen a
lot of Transformations we see creatures
as they are and we see them very grossly
we haven't seen something evolve so
maybe maybe we go from uh Frieza to you
know a different freezer yeah we get our
Evolution from Super Saiyan you do have
I mean this is such a this is such a
bridge but you do have vecina with his
like weird tentacle elevation thing that
he does and sort of the tentacle nature
of or I guess I don't know if they're
more like stocks of the Mind flare so I
don't know maybe it's just the upside
down it's like we love tentacles clearly
someone I also feel like will is gonna
parallel vecina next season whereas this
is an 11 paralleled vechna I feel like
next season there's it's not a
coincidence both homeboys were drawn the
the thing the same drawing yeah remember
the shot of them drawing they even
framed it the same that's that's not a
coincidence all right so we'll check the
tapes in two years I think it's a combo
attack uh now who do we think created
the upside down how do we think this all
began because it seems to me we talked
before the breaks we have debates about
this so what are your thoughts up front
I think it was like a also in the Big
Bang like the world and the universe as
we know it was created and also the
upside down was created at the same time
because it feels like yeah it's always
been there like I feel like the
particles mind Flay or whatever you want
to call it had just always been kind of
swirling about in the upside down so 111
uh sent Henry one becna through that was
the first time anyone had ever crossed
over and then it paused yeah and then it
paused because we know that it's stuck
at a time right which wouldn't make
sense if it had always been around for
why then but that would make sense plus
we saw the upside down right like before
it had been sort of formed into Hawkins
right before the whole before like it
had a it broke the seal the Tupperware
Gap right that's the problem
I mean it gets messy in there that's how
mold happens yeah what do you think oh
well I want to say 11 but also did we
establish how old the the universe is
upside down no that's why that's what
we're positive that's what we're talking
about is like if [ __ ] one who created it
but how long it's been there is also as
unknown right I feel like it was either
some sort of you know conglomerate of
all of the kids that were being tested
in the facility right somehow they it
was like the master plan and that was
created as a sort of I don't know maybe
a side effect of it all over this time
you know maybe something was off because
these kids were created in this universe
and so it created upside down either
that or I'm thinking I'm trying to think
through some of the traumatic episodes
they've already shown 11 go through in
our past and maybe she created it in
some semblancer it's one of those things
where it's it was a tiny universe and
then it grew and it grew over time
because we've been seeing a lot of that
in this last season so that's what I'm
thinking with upside down is it's tied
to 11 or for the kids somehow yeah it's
hard to it's hard to know right like it
may after the first batch of episodes
you can totally make that argument of
like oh 11 created the upside down when
she banished uh one into that into the
upside down
um but you know we've seen it now formed
prior to that with when he gets there he
says like oh it's in this place and you
know I could mold it to whatever I
wanted it to be or whatever he says
um
but to your point which I think makes a
lot of sense why Hawkins why is Hawkins
where it is sort of the most active if
it has been there since the beginning of
time and like presumably then could be
and there's an upside down for
everywhere on Earth so my theory on that
is like Mount wundergore so mount
wundergore in comics uh Marvel Comics is
a mountain that's really really close to
a magic Point there's the Earth's
thinner there so Scarlet Witch and
Agatha Harkness and all them they have
more abilities there because they're
closer to the source what if
11 is a byproduct of the upside down not
the upside down is a byproduct of 11.
what if all their mental abilities come
from being in this area which is
attached thinly to the upside down like
I think the neighborhood is too integral
to the story to not be a reason for
something not a byproduct of something
especially with this next season clearly
taking place where the world is becoming
the upside down I think that whole town
is thinner or closer to it and that's
caused all these kids to get messy it's
like The Buffy hell mouth exactly yeah
vote number one right so vekna when he
was a kid yeah maybe I don't know
something happened
because we saw the all the uh you know
Freddy Krueger stuff like where you know
that house was messed up like that house
caused problems right you also like he
didn't start messing around with his
powers right until he moved his family
moved into that house which is Hawkins I
think Hawkins is the answer I think the
town's spooky the house is
a gate though yeah I think it's the
thinnest point in a thin point right
yeah so like the whole town instead of A
Haunted House movie had a haunted town
movie yeah and that's your that's your
focal point and then the whole happens
in that town and it spreads and spreads
because the upside Down's gotten bigger
in storyline and in space every season
like physically we've seen more of it
and in storyline I think I think Hawkins
is a problem yeah well here's my
question on that though what's with the
Russians like did they not have a role
in opening this thing are they just like
Curious they found out about it somehow
are they not involved in creating them
and then if it's the whole earth right
there's gonna be other weak points like
there's going to be other places that
have weak thin areas we didn't see it go
as big so maybe they just have access to
like you know creating these weapons
from finding one of these things sure
because if it happens all over the world
there's like we've only seen two places
but next season we could find out like
you know Tasmania yeah
but like yeah we'll see so uh what do
you think is gonna be happening with Max
in season five what is going on with Max
I personally think she's gonna be our
next season's wheel I think will is
going to be our lead and I think that
she is going gonna be we'll talk about
that a bit I think I think willser lead
and she is going to be the one that's in
and out of Storyline by way of
unconsciousness maybe she Taps into the
upside down in the way what do you think
yeah poor Max that was uh that was
another moment is she one of the five do
we count her technically yeah we'll get
to that because she died for a minute he
said yeah
um yeah I think I hope she comes back to
us I hope she's just not laid up in a
bed or a chair All Season like I hope
she becomes like active and you know at
the very end of the season she's able to
ride a skateboard into the sunset you
know like yeah but I don't like I don't
think there's a sunset
I'm hopeful oh yeah there's been several
times watching season seven me and my
roommate were watching it and season
seven sorry season four
uh
yeah
[Applause]
all right when we were watching the
first part those first seven episodes
uh me and my roommate were like oh we
forgot this wasn't like a kids show
there's kids who are uh in it but it is
not for children and that it goes to
your point of like oh yeah we might not
get a happy ending this is not a
children show oh yeah nothing much oh
what do you think's going on with Max uh
I I I'm gonna be honest I don't think
it's gonna be the brightest uh next
season for Max obviously uh things I
think this is going to be creating a lot
of tension is trying to get max out they
can't even find Max right now you know
there's no semblance of Max in there I
think Max might help fight vechna
somewhere in the upside down
you know part of the hive mind right
that has been
established in this last season but I
definitely think they're going to you
know I'm hoping for the happy ending I
hope they'll pull max out by the end of
the season but I think Max is going to
be one of those
fighters on the inside you know just
trying to to derail that that's why I
think she's our will I think she's our
Inside Man yeah yeah but she's Behind
Enemy Lines because she has experience
with it will was just like I'm a little
kid where am I yeah what was connected
and then disconnected and now he's still
got that that sense there but uh and we
we got some spooky stuff from will in
season two they haven't really Revisited
too much with the Slugs yeah with the
Slugs I wish that they still had little
inklings of that throughout the next
Seasons or the last seasons but also I
think that Max is now you know tied into
the upside down I think Max's are like
uh acrobat and Oceans 11 and Wales or
George Clooney okay all right like I
feel like yeah
brought in the Clooney okay okay so uh
with the upside down being stuck in time
we don't actually resolve it this season
oh this is a quote that's why there's
quotes there who said this uh this is
The Duffer brother okay one of the
brothers
the brothers Duffer said the following
uh they're talking about it being stuck
in time they said quote we don't
actually resolve it this season but it
plays that moment where they realize
it's frozen in time it's a huge part of
season five and so we just wanted to
just put it out there and get people
talking about it and thinking about it
so with that in mind I do think that
ties into all of our beliefs with the
upside down is they said that they
didn't really lean into it but it's an
important moment I think that's
important and I also think the confusion
around the upside down and that tying to
Max and the lack of congruity between
11. because 11 like was doing stuff with
Max and then she came back and seemed
surprised by it like you guys notice 11
was like dealing with the loss of Max
and crying over her and then like we get
back to the world like two days later
and she's like what's going on with Max
and I was like you were there uh yeah
I'm wondering what I think we're gonna
find out what happened in those two days
in season five I think we might see some
scenes that were cut maybe for length
but also for story in season five but I
think the stuck in time element is going
to be tied into those two days in some
weird way oh I don't know about that I
think the two days was just they were
driving from what Albuquerque to Hawkins
didn't see Steve say bye to to more we
didn't see like any moment with poor
Eddie like think about all the things we
didn't see that they would fill
yeah oh yeah and Dustin was in the
upside down with him right so he came
back that all happened through the
trailer park I guess and like he
literally the last line Steve said to
Eddie is like don't go be a hero then he
died yeah how are you not gonna let
Steve like I feel like that closure is
going to be happening in season five for
whatever reason
not to change the topics but do we think
we'll see Eddie flashback or Ed I don't
know I mean Eddie as the character from
the albums the the Judas Priest what's
the rock icon Eddie the the like yeah
he comes back he's all ripped apart he's
metal as hell yeah cool he's an undead
Beast he's also fighting with Max he's
just like wielding his actions I was not
expecting to like Eddie watching the
trailers I was like okay sure that guy
um
uh I know who that is uh I've played DND
with that guy
um but I love him so much or loved him
so much and I hope we get I mean that
would be super fun yeah I mean we saw
Barb for a second we got a little bit of
fun
was like I've remembered every single
person that I've killed I was like I
don't know Nancy was like just like
having a having a good night like yeah I
don't know so yeah I do the quote that I
didn't realize was a quote until it was
too late was about the pause and I do
think that's going to be the entire
basis for season five like I honestly
think it is it is huge how would you
guys use a pause in time narratively
would you have it be something that like
that's how they save everyone
well and now that the upside down is
sort of taking over the Overworld I
don't know whatever we want to call it
do we think that right side up it's
gonna yeah do we think that like the the
right side up is going to revert somehow
in time or something or maybe like
sinkhole into the upside down or maybe
I'm wondering if like people who died
but were alive two years ago might
that's how we get it
it's things in the uh uh the right side
up start going back in time as well I
don't know that could be kind of wonky
and it's a show about Nostalgia we're
bringing back the 80s literally yeah it
was obviously in the 80s couldn't have
it we're going back to the beginning I
don't know what they're gonna do with
the time thing I think it's interesting
I also think that it's interesting the
duffers came out and we're like this is
what we're gonna do in two years so
interesting that they're like this is
super important we want people to start
talking about it because they're usually
pretty cagey yeah they're well they're
teasing a lot right now too and and
we're just all theorizing right now so
that is an interesting one that they
dropped that do you guys want next
season to be episodic week tweet because
I do I always wanted to be episodically
because I want to talk about it more
I don't know I mean it's it's a win like
they're gonna break yeah yeah it's been
all all at once kind of sort of I'm just
like that's like that play intermission
yeah I do like the two parts though
I don't know what do you think I mean
it's traditionally been binge style
right and then uh this last season I
think they wanted to build up some of
that that hype either that or you know
keep people on that platform for an
extra month who knows but but you know
they had the final two episodes come out
I was thinking the meta like that the
accountant was like yeah
July
we need a subscription
but but yeah they had those final two
episodes come out and they gave us some
some breathe room in there but I always
did wonder why we needed the the two
episodes specifically to be that volume
two I uh I I thought it summed it up
well but obviously week to week I think
gives a lot more breathing room it's
just the boys I like talking weekly
about the boys I feel like I feel like
the boy stays in the conversation longer
I just think this the streaming platform
doesn't allow for that has Netflix done
anything like that Netflix hasn't been
Amazon and and HBO and Hulu
it's time for Barbie talk uh no so they
did mention the five deaths in the
finale yeah I did see someone in the
comments say if you count them there
were five
yeah put someone in the chat
now that we're in spoiler talk because I
didn't count five I counted preppy
mckendall yeah uh I counted uh if we
want to counter coming back from the
dead ish uh but the finale episodes
right yeah so Max Max counts yeah that's
true
episode prior so that doesn't count who
uh oh sorry Matthew Modine uh Papa oh I
was ready yeah I think they were saying
in the last two episodes got it okay
okay
so okay so Brenner yes
and then JK he's not there's no no that
counts less than Max
Eddie Jason Max Jason's preppy
Russian guy Yuri yeah but he didn't die
he flew them to safety okay because they
were like you were a hero once upon a
time not Russian artists on her side
with Papa Eddie Jason Max that's the
four we got a high school kid Papa what
high school high school kid that's Jason
I think oh yes they're saying Papa Max
Eddie high school kids four do you think
The Duffer brothers can't count that is
yeah I mean yeah Jason and Eddie were
the only dust we saw on screen I would I
would put Papa in even though it was the
episode before and like vector didn't
die and Max didn't really die we can
count and if we're counting those yeah
some people think that we killed five
what the hell yeah there's two guys in
the helicopter
have you seen that some people saying
that Pop-Pop didn't die because we
didn't see him like take a last breath
oh we just kind of left a message
to the thing I was like you're dead yeah
like it's not like Star Wars you can get
lightsaber to the Torso this is
theoretically our world yeah some people
are saying demogorgon sure I think like
that that specific demogorgon was like
uh uh that wasn't the season one
demogorgon yeah it was like a who cares
democrine yeah
[Music]
Owens don't know who that is it the
Russian general Maybe
oh Paul oh right
yeah
see Paul Riser bite it no he didn't die
who made the upside down we're calling
it five all right speaking of we're
calling him four we we here are calling
in four uh speaking of deaths season
five is guaranteed to stack up a body
count I personally think it's gonna be
like Mark Ruffalo says and everyone dies
I think it's gonna be rough I think it's
gonna be a mess but I want to do a full
on Deadpool
my oceans as well I'm feeling sorry to
bring it back but I remember the
technicality remember when they did the
news report in Hawkins and they reported
all the deaths from the earthquake
what was the number there maybe they're
just talking about General
hospitals
that like Lucas's little sister died in
the earthquake and you were like oh it
just didn't included
I do feel like something happened in
that two days I feel like season five
but I want to do a full-on Deadpool uh
so I want to know we're gonna do votes
of four and I want to see who ends up
the most likely to die there's gonna be
multiples but do we think Hopper bites
it next season but what do you votes of
four
I want to see who all of us think die
okay like I want to see the stack of the
like the unanimous death so what do we
think about Hopper I think yeah it'll be
Hopper Jonathan will he's going down a
lot he's just getting ahead and
uh I gotta say Dustin that was why I was
gonna break everyone's heart okay I'm
gonna go person by person that way we
don't get Miss anybody all right
popper yes or no
David Harbor
no okay so he's not unanimous alive him
and 11 have a sunset moment or she dies
and he's very sad okay I agree that
Hopper makes it because I feel like he's
already like had the bait into the shot
yeah it's very true it also kind of
undermine like if only five people die
one of them like nine season three so uh
okay Steve I thought Steve was gonna
bite it this whole season I think they
were very clever at one point they were
like we're not getting out of this and
then the next shot was Steve and then it
cut to like a scene of them being like
we're not getting out of this and they
kept doing those great like I want to
have six kids and like I felt like he
was about to go to the farm a lot yeah
he was getting oh that seemed brutal
when the like bats were going after Oh I
thought he was gonna get it oh man so
because of that I personally don't think
Steve's gonna bite it I think all next
season and be like you guys love this
guy and they're gonna toy with us and he
makes it through so no Steve for me
personally what do you think I think
he'll survive but just to poke a hole in
your fake out death so they're gonna
survive the whole way there was uh uh
Steve Yoon in The Walking Dead he almost
died under that uh trash can and then
got his head back so and we love stuff
yeah yeah so I don't think anyone's safe
but I don't think Steve's gonna get it
okay I I we need to stop using The
Walking Dead
Steve's gonna die Steve's gonna die
Steve's gonna go okay because anytime
you give that that future was it yeah
anytime
character does that usually in media
that's at least part of my theory is
they're they're gonna go it's the don't
kill the cat but I think they
manipulated us I think it's like
intentional yeah he's gone okay I'm
alone We're alone in this because I feel
like the internet's with us here all
right we'll speed up in these next ones
uh we got Joyce
Winona Ryder herself we'll just do yay
or nay nay
Nate lives
he dies lives okay uh Nancy lives lives
with the big gun like oh my God she gets
a
bazooka
she put the barrel back
uh lips lives I think she's our
Sigourney Weaver uh Jonathan
does
dies I wanted them to die for so long
not our new Stoner I
think that's not great but I do think
like I think there's always going to be
people that like see the love triangle
uncomfortably and I think at the end
it's probably gonna be Steve because we
love Steve but also if they introduce a
new love interest I think Jonathan makes
it I can't stop shipping I can't stop
shipping Nancy and Robin I can't do it
oh yeah interesting I did struggle with
like I didn't feel the chemistry as well
between Steve and Nancy this year's the
other Seasons that I was like yeah do I
want them together like they were
talking about it so he wants kids I
don't think she does as much as I just
said I wanted Jonathan to die for a very
long time I felt so bad for Jonathan
this season
screw that guy
like it's rough for him the writing he
got yeah he'd be a great young Ghost
Rider though uh will
no imagine a Norman Reedus Ghost Rider
with flashbacks to Young uh with him oh
Jonathan I could totally see like a
future impact because they look like the
same dude both Ghost Rider they even
have the same haircut
that's like the whole like weathered
I've seen the pen and stick anyway
Marvel they're very appellation
yeah speaking of will you see in the
abyss and look back I think will is our
protagonist next season I think will
sacrifices himself I think Wills are
like ah at the end of the season death
I like the concept of that full circle
there but I think Will's going to live
and in 20 years they're gonna make
another stranger things thing and it's
gonna be like that you know back to
Dairy situations
that's true yeah yeah I'm so sad uh Bush
era again
can't wait for new metal to be popular
so I'm gonna say will lives okay I
thought you were gonna say they're gonna
do like a Harry Potter uh seven part two
situation where they like age them all
up
I can still do a return to Hawkins thing
we had dead dead alive I think Joyce
dies will lives I think it's either one
of the other and I think Joyce is gonna
die okay this is a big one because when
they said five deaths and the subplot
for Lucas came into play I was most
worried for Lucas I didn't I thought
it'd be either Max or Lucas and once the
bully plot came in I was like are they
about to so I was was worried for him
the most this season next to Steve Lucas
bites it or lives
lives he better live God damn it
acting like some of the best I've Seen
On TV like he was so good this season
like what he was able to do with just
dialogue while there's so much going on
like if you look at all the special
effects and dude's just in a room like
action is highball yeah
we can add more people to this list I I
put the list together just like sort of
our season one main cast because I think
he's not on this list uh some other
people are not alone because it looks
like the Hawkins thing is the point of
next season like that last shot that
Smallville shot but they're like look at
all the cast in Everglades uh I do think
that's the core so that's why I think
Max is laid up because I think they're
gonna focus on our Hawkins Duo where
it's set up uh what do you think about
Dustin
he gonna die yeah I hate to say it he's
gonna go
die I think he's dead I think this is
our first unanimous I think yeah I think
I think it's our okay he is official one
of the Deadpool he's so loved yeah I
mean Steve is too but like God damn if
they kill him we will kill ourselves
yeah that's a little dark oh Susie will
Riot she doesn't even burn the whole
world down I love that because he's
gonna hack the world yeah
he's actually just a war games prequel
so this next one I think he has to get
better first because he was a bit of a
prick Mike does Mike make it this uh
this next season I think he's got to
grow up a little before he bites it
personally
yeah I think Mike survives uh yeah Mike
surprise he lives he lives he's like the
that solid kind of character that
carries through things that's just sort
of this weird backbone that whether we
like it or not he's there a lot less
depth for you guys than I expected all
right he's dead he's dead no he's dead
because either 11 I keep doing these
either ORS either 11 or Mike will die
right they can't what about 11 Hopper or
Mike
if I had to pick one out of those three
only one yeah uh uh I would probably
pick 11. I think I think 11's gonna die
I think that's how they close the I
think that's how they right side the
upside down yeah I think 11 will
sacrifice
Oh no you're fine I think will and I
think Will and 11 are my most likely to
personally it will be shitty if the the
general or whoever it was he was like
take the shot is right and they're like
yeah if we kill 11 like that upside down
could have just killed the kids
it's gonna be dark when any like we've
grown up with these kids so like now
that we're to the point where we're
gonna start losing them in two years it
is gonna be interesting to see what that
feels like and what it does narratively
like she could solve the problem I kind
of hope that's not the case I hope it's
not so simple but I think that could be
an option what do you think Eric do you
think 11 will live or die I think she
lives I think she survives I think
she'll it'll be murky like she'll
sacrifice herself and we'll be like
you know kind of thing and she'll just
it'll be a presumed dead yeah she I do
see like in an instance where similar to
that uh you know in the Batman we just
watched Batman sacrifice himself and
we're like oh no he died and then he's
like I'm alive
I actually get like ripped apart
not Catwoman this time but Alfred um we
were talking before the show about will
and his sort of like we we don't get a
lot of his relationship with the Mind
player but we got a taste uh but I
wanted you didn't you wouldn't tell me
so I think the thing that ties the
upside down to staying open might not be
11 because that is what the guy want to
take the shot would be I think will
might be the thing keeping it open
because she has power he didn't he was a
kid stuck there so I'm wondering if he's
like a thing stuck in the dam because
he's just a dude so what if Will is I've
used this reference before today but
Infinity war end game what if the arc
that felt so underserved was because
this was only half of his Arc and we saw
through the painting uh you know he's
like you're the heart you're the blah
blah he kept putting other people above
him we were supposed to feel always like
you know he's just there to support I
think he's actually the lead of the next
season I think he's going to grow
heroically I think we're gonna see
himself actualized I think they're like
floodgates are gonna open he's going to
like reveal some things and then I think
we're gonna see that he's actually the
other side of the 11 coin I think that
the the Battle of Good and Evil was
Vector at 11. I think the Battle of what
the upside down is is actually gonna be
willing 11. or hear me out they will
forget his birthday again and that's his
village
that and it says 0001
exactly but I do think the slug thing is
important I do think the rubbing in the
back of the head thing is important I do
think that painting is important I do
think that Arc feeling like not really
complete I feel like our next season is
going to be more like reuniting your
rear night will leading us yeah I will
say this and and you guys might disagree
with me will is such a weird character
on this show because from the very first
season he's had a bad news
no but you know he was absent for a lot
of that season because you're stuck in
the upside down he wasn't having cast
chemistry with all these other
characters that we were sort of falling
in love with uh the whole season was
about him but we didn't get a lot of him
I feel like we've kind of had the same
situation for the uh proceeding that's
not a word uh three seasons right the
three seasons that followed I do think
some similar to Max this season where
she was a kind of a side character and
then whoa my gosh so much more fleshed
out and has a great backstory and story
I do think we'll get that from will next
week I agree yeah
yeah because will is so important season
one and we haven't done that a lot yeah
so I think five is going to end with him
as important as one yeah I feel for him
and you know he clearly wants to just
bust out of the closet like and clearly
he's all about Mike and he's kind of
jealous of 11 but like that's kind of
become his sister so it's a weird I feel
like they're just gonna finally
hopefully realize that whole storyline
that's what I feel like we've been
waiting for that's the thing that's
clogging the damn I think once he gets
that out once he tells Mike once he gets
that freedom things will be running up
that hill yeah no I will say the one
time Jonathan was not stoned for this
interview
my brother's gay
that scene was so prejudice
do we think any of these kids you sort
of said that will might be the next one
or eleven or whatever uh 12 or 12. yeah
um do we think any of the kids sort of
have innate powers that they could
trigger with their traumatic memories
I'd be worried if it gets to be like a
New Mutants thing sure
yeah I think will could could do some
destructive stuff he's also got the
reasons for it dude's picked up yeah
he's got some carry energy and he's
complex yeah it hasn't come out yet he's
been possessed like literally we saw
that exorcism did on him and vechner or
whoever I think mindflare came out of
him so there's probably some residue
power in him somewhere that might get
activated I think we're gonna see a
little bit of a dark side to will maybe
I could do that because he's just he's
been I call him like like sweet baby boy
like sweet baby will
um I feel like that's gonna come out a
little bit he's going to stand up for
himself and it's he's gonna have to have
that struggle I think that scene in the
car of him like not being able to even
share that with anyone I think that's
important like he's not able to let it
out except for with his brother and his
brother's not been around so like I feel
like all that pent-up energy is gonna
come out in a big way whether it's good
or evil I think there's a reason The
Duffer Brothers wouldn't let him change
his haircut as weird as that sounds Kim
being trapped and restrained and it's
like a visual of him being stuck as a
child there's a visual of him not
evolving like everyone else I like that
we're trying to keep him stuck everyone
else's house dude's in a bowl cut yeah
it's a visual of him being stagnant yeah
and I think he's going to change just
like Toby Maguire in Spider-Man 3.
sometimes you got the email alone
um thank you again uh athletic greens
we've been taking athletic ag-1 from
athletic greens to help boost our
immunity and give us energy throughout
the day A bunch of us just came back
from Texas traveling is always wonky so
I've been throwing ag-1 at my co-workers
who will be back in the break room
tomorrow some of them
um uh so that they can get their immune
systems back and going with one
delicious scoop of ag1 you're absorbing
75 high quality vitamins minerals Whole
Food Source superfoods probiotics and
adaptogens a whole bunch of good stuff
to help you start your day right this
blend this blend right here of
ingredients supports your gut health
your nervous system your immune system
your energy your recovery your focus and
your aging
uh ag-1 is also super lifestyle friendly
so if you happen to be keto or paleo or
vegan or dairy free or gluten-free all
that kind of stuff ag-1 has ingredients
in it that you know will help you stay
on your diet uh it also supports better
sleep quality better recovery mental
Clarity and alertness it's also a lot
cheaper than getting you know a million
different supplements from a million
different places we all had that GNC
subscription when we were like in high
school uh you don't have to do that
anymore
um you're investing in an all-in-one
nutritional insurance and with every
purchase athletic greens donates to
organizations helping to get nutritious
food to kids in need including no kid
hungry here in the United States so
right now it is your time to reclaim
your health and arm your immune system
with convenient daily nutrition just one
scoop of water just one scoop in a cup
of water every day that's all you need
to do no need for a million different
pills and supplements to look out for
your health and to make it easy athletic
greens is going to give you a free year
supply of immune supporting vitamin D
and five free travel packs like this one
with your first purchase this is super
convenient you can I think koi keeps him
in his car
um they're great genius so all you need
to do is visit athleticgreens.com break
room all one word again that is
athleticqueens.com break room to take
ownership over your health and pick up
the ultimate daily nutritional Insurance
thank you so much I know we're going
along but we do want to get some to some
of your guys's questions I'm going to
move a light stand so that I can read
that
um but if someone can see you want to
read the yellow I got I can see the
green or yellow uh yeah any of them any
of them so I have a question for that so
ask her ask it up and for you pineapple
on Pizza yes all day every day yeah like
enthusiastic don't deny until you try
have you tried I've had it it's fine I'm
never gonna say you can't order it on
your pizza but it's you know it is sweet
and savory but I I have other toppings
you seem resistant that I'm going to
first okay because it's not your
favorite you're not against it yeah I
support that that's a rare neutral on
pineapple yeah
when it comes to pizza toppings and
pizza toppings only okay
um a bunch of people by the way
returning to some polls that we put uh
Taryn ederson is great 57 of you uh
would like Taryn to be the next
Wolverine I think you'd be a really fun
choice I also think like Marvel pretty
much Nails it with casting and man
vilani
stole my heart she's so fun
um episode five tonight we can see more
darling moments of her loving Marvel
like we do
um also mindflare or vechna who is in
charge 66 of people I'm gonna call that
66.6 percent of people said is in charge
I think most of us sort of agree with
that could be someone else probably not
at this point I think we kind of have
learned a lot of what we're going to
learn about the upside down
um
let's see
um Azalea Rivera says at new records
will there be something worse than vecna
in season five or more of vac now we're
definitely getting more of akna yeah and
I think decoy's point also could be
worse so I think it's going to evolve
yeah I think that spider like you think
we've seen since season one it's gonna
it's we're gonna see more of it for a
reason yeah oh yeah
um our good friend meso JD gaming and
Vlogs long name mezzo uh says is Max's
Soul still alive is she hiding in a
memory is she trapped in fact in vekna
since he absorbs them and then when he
dies is she free that's a really
interesting take on on sort of her
comatose state do we think like that's
how Max rebounds we just needed to die
maybe she gets her eyes back or
something maybe she wasn't a dream like
there's that moment where his dream was
a dream yeah I do think that was pointed
I do think that was a thing like maybe
she's stuck like in an envelope of time
like she's she's Edgar yeah
somewhere in an envelope in time yeah I
think that could be a thing
um let's see I also see a poll that says
who do you think is more likely to die
41 of you said well but very close was
another 40 saying Jonathan we hate the
buyers here
they're gone get them out of here get
them out of here
um where was Dimitri in the last scene
of season four part two will someone
remind me who the heck Dimitri is
is he not the guy who died yeah I
thought he died was he the friend the
Russian friend yeah but he died in the
carnival right
that was Alexis yeah Dimitri was the guy
that was like helping him out from
inside the prison and ended up teaming
up with my thing right okay what was
that because Enzo was the guy that was
betrayed them I think Dimitri was the
guy that was helping and then ended up
being like an ally so who's Alexi he's
the guy Alexis the picture where he's
like you know sipping out season three
yeah
with the girly hair yeah okay so I think
this is
someone in the chat will remind us
um okay a couple more questions
um is that it for Russia's side of
things with another demon Gordon said I
say absolutely not there's they they
they need to die that that loose end up
I'm so confused and the Slugs the Slugs
yeah what are the Slugs doing what's
happening there Will's inside's turning
into slugs
those insides turning into slime
um Zechariah Robert says what role will
play in season five I think we kind of
answer that a little bit we think he's
probably going to be next to 11 and
vecina one of the most important
characters in that season right
um what if this is from Chad hayslip
what if Eddie could come back because he
died in the upside down did we see his
body in the I don't think we did it yeah
um nobody I was wondering when the uncle
was gonna be like where's my nephew's
body yeah
tell me about that yeah that's enough
okay cool he was a hero where is he we
don't have any precedent of characters
dying in the upside down yet right I was
thinking Barb was maybe but but it sort
of seemed like the oh the right side up
sort of turned into the upside down in
the pool yeah maybe they didn't quite
have their upside down logic set at that
time but I don't think they could just
like rewrite it now but maybe they could
say like you know that wasn't fully or
whatever but I don't think we've seen a
body well we've we've seen them get you
know dragged into the UPS I mean I guess
it has been connected in very congruent
right with all the characters in this
season with the opening the gates and
everything so
broken yeah he could come back as Edge
from Iron Maiden uh apparently Dimitri
and Enzo are the same character okay
okay great so the traitor is uh uh he
flew he flew them out yeah because when
uh his wife in Alaska yeah after Hopper
decapitated the demogorgon uh that scene
was so good oh yeah they played the
score
when they matched the run up the hill
with the stranger things theme I was
like yeah oh that was great do that it
was good uh a couple a couple more I
think you were I know her a little
longer than we usually are but we're
talking stranger things how could we not
um
mediocre Christ that can't be how you
pronounce your name but I apologize uh
says actually I think all of vecon's
victims could team up against him when
vekna takes his victims they become part
of him so maybe everyone the cree fan
the creel family Chrissy Max Etc could
fight him we did see their bodies in the
upside down
strapped I mean I don't know how we give
them New Life maybe we could find some
way there's like a lot of weird energy
happening in the upside down maybe 11 in
a doctor strange Multiverse of Madness
Type of Way can kind of puppet dead
bodies on the upside down and might be
able to do that to sort of Master of
Puppets yeah
it has to be there has to be a deeper
reason there
um which we called by the way remember
that we did what song yeah I think you
did say yeah yeah people were like
what's the song gonna be I'm like from
the time what he'd listened to what year
it was Master of Puppets
Two Minutes to Midnight like Iron Maiden
well I like that because there's a clock
theme
[Music]
thank you so much for joining us on the
break room today we will be back
tomorrow I'm sure we'll be talking about
Miss Marvel episode 5 which is always
when Marvel does the craziest stuff in
their shows uh and and we'll see you
back then a bunch of us are going to be
back tomorrow I won't be I get to go
back behind the scenes so um come come
visit us watch Miss Marvel in the
morning and visit us tomorrow thank you
so much for watching we'll see you later
right